okay Rich yeah I have a quick question
it's not regarding the metoo movement
okay it's something else uh have you
been in few ltrs and as soon as the
marriage talk comes in uh usually the
relationship ends in a few weeks or
months okay so how do you navigate that
how do you keep the relationship going
on after you have the kind of the
marriage talk okay so you're not
interested in the marriage part no no
absolutely no so so it's an absolute nut
how old are you
35 and how old are the women that you're
typically dating
in their early 30s early 30s and
um at what point in the timeline does
the I'd like to get married at some
point conversation come up
it usually comes up after a year too
okay and how do you usually respond to
that like how do you address it
I usually address like I'm not
interested in having the government
involved in our lives I'm gonna continue
with it relationship but
I don't want the government to
participate in our bedroom and how does
she typically respond to that
they're kind of upset
in a sense that I guess that woman's
dream to get married and you're saying
no to it kind of crushes her dreams so
okay so I mean there's a couple of
different approaches that you can use to
this right you're going to get women
that are just hell-bent on getting
married right they just
they just want to find a guy and get
married they want the party they want
the you know the invitations the
reception the honeymoon
the videos the photographers all that
stuff makes them feel special I get it
it's a big party okay
um women are more often not pretty much
hell bands on it they don't understand
it from the guy's perspective when guys
start to unplug and they see that it's
not such a good deal and there's too
much risk exposure and it's difficult to
manage and then living together and all
that sort of stuff
that's when they're starting to like
sort of push back in it so you're open
to having a long-term relationship you
just don't want to get married or live
in the way that the state looks as a
marriage is that what you're asking yes
absolutely yeah that's correct and it's
kind of funny things like
if you Google any articles like if
you've been living with a guy for x
amount of years yeah and he hasn't
proposed it's like just leaving there
isn't a single article or anything
that's just like hey stay with this guy
or anything like that yeah and on top of
that you have family friends and you
have
everybody's like oh he hasn't proposed
you've been together for three years or
it's time to live he's not the one yeah
you know um
yeah I'm I'm trying to relate to it a
little bit more because
I mean because of what I do and I've and
I'm very open with the fact that I'm not
interested in marriage I'm never going
to get married again uh I don't have a
strong interest and want to live with a
woman anytime in the immediate future
um I actually did a video in my car the
other day talking about why it's not
ideal to live with a woman and why it's
to your advantage to try to avoid that
so that'll be on the entrepreneurs and
cars Channel soon but I think that if
you're reasonably honest with her right
and if you're dealing with women that
have strong strong desire for you so
from the get-go there's a few things
that you can do you should be dating
women that aren't overtly stating
immediately that their goal is marriage
because one of the things you're doing
you're wasting both of your time I mean
if you're just looking for a long-term
relationship with a girl that's sort of
keeping your frame that's going to be a
compliment to your life you're going to
keep dealing with women I mean if
they're overtly staying like on dating
apps if they're stating in the apps my
name is Becky I'm 34 years old I have a
great job in Corporate America I don't
have any kids yet I'd like to have
family so if you're not interested in
family or marriage and swipe left then
look I mean
don't waste your time or waste your time
right like if you want a dater or if you
want to meet her or something like that
and it comes up she's going to be pretty
strongly opinionated about the idea of
getting married and having kids and I
don't think that you should try to
change that opinion of it but
what you should do in my opinion is date
women that aren't interested in marriage
or aren't overtly stating it at least
when you meet them right so
um it's not going to be immediately
crammed down your throat right and the
other thing that you have to understand
about women is that their sexual
strategy will adopt your sexual strategy
so what I what I mean by that is if
she's hell-bent on getting married
and you're not if she likes you enough
she will stay with you even though
you're not going to marry her
do you understand what I'm saying here
yes but I kind of disagree on this one
okay I think it's like even if you're
the best option for her yeah her idea of
marriage okay and kind of you're saying
no today it's pretty much crushing her
dreams and everything so it doesn't
matter how successful how best option is
since women are emotional and they run
by the emotions they just think for the
Exit Plan yeah but look man I mean I can
say this you know for myself and for a
lot of the guys that I work with on a
close basis women will abandon uh their
hopes wants dreams and desires if you
are a high enough value guy I'm not
going to say that you know they're going
to do it all the time 100 of the time
they're not going to do it there's just
going to be something to be helping
Anton [__] or get off the pot if you're
not going to marry me then I'm going to
move on if that's the case she's done
you a favor dude if that's all she
wanted from you was just uh get a ring
live with you sign a marriage contract
and have a couple kids that let's be
honest 50 of the time you're never going
to see them after seven to eight years
after you get divorced because she's
going to have custody and all your
money's gonna flow to her so what's the
freaking point right she's done you a
favor if she's that hell-bent because
women like that that are that hell-bent
on marriage they're not they don't want
you they want a husband
and there's a big difference between
that so they're doing you a favor if
they're that hell-bent on it fine go
good luck
most of those women and what I say most
at least 51 of them most of those women
at some point in the future if you're a
high enough value guy if you're
captivating if you're a gentleman if you
make good money if you do everything
right in the bedroom for her she'll come
knocking on your door later on in the
future even when she's married to the
next guy I'm telling you dude I've had
women that I dated in my 20s that have
messaged me
decade deck and a half later
oh you know I'm really sorry I did this
to you you were the best I ever had I
love you so much that it likes it's like
[__] you're married like you like I can
see you on Facebook you're married with
kids like what the hell is wrong with
you right like
when you when you start to understand
these behaviors and you let and you
surrender certain things like okay well
you know certain women just won't stay
with me okay fine you've done me a favor
go go find some schlep that's that's
okay fine no problem I'll look past your
50 Notch count I'll look past the fact
that you're bringing kids from two
different guys you know to the table
I'll look past your your debt I'll look
past your mental disorders and the pills
you have to pop I look past all this
[__] and put a ring on your finger
because that's a good idea right the
vast majority of women today are not
even marriage material they're barely
even LTR type of material right so it's
like if they go let them go blessing and
release let them go but if you're dating
a bunch of women simultaneously in a
non-monogamous fashion the cream Rises
the top hey Michael where do we stand I
dig your Vibe I don't want to share you
I want to claim you you know I'm not
seeing anybody else other guys are
invisible to me blah blah blah okay fine
and you know you can remind her at that
point I'm happy today and keep saying
you and I you know I feel the same way
blah blah blah like you have to talk
sort of thing but just understand I'm
not I'm never going to get married or
I'm never going to live in the way that
the state views as a marriage
okay I'm not saying that I won't see you
for a long time I'm not going to say
that maybe we might live together at
some point right but I'm not going to
ever do this thing right and if she
wants to stick around then that's her
choice but she can't bother you about it
in the future
you know you made your position very
very clear it's like if you go to the
dealership and you buy a freaking
Lamborghini you can't complain to the
dealer afterwards that you're not
getting 40 miles to the gallon like your
Prius does
right like you've made it clear what
your position is so I think you have to
manage it a little bit better I think
you have to let certain women go and
just surrender to it as beautiful or as
whatever boxes they might tick off for
you
that's why you got to put yourself first
man this is why the whole mental point
of origin and doing your own thing
matters more than anything else because
it puts you in a position where you can
be spoiled for more Choice with a higher
caliber of women and the ones that go
you're fine because you can replace them
very very easily I don't know does that
make sense to you man
it does yes
it's just a thing like you can't really
fix it like there's no hey you know
memorize these lines or let me hypnotize
her with some woo-woo [__] or
something like this it's like none of
that stuff actually exists it's just you
know it's one of those things that
happens in Love and War and some women
will just because they don't get their
way they're just gonna go well I want to
get married okay well if that's what you
want to do then I'll miss you
two I agree to some moment the piece of
paper is more important than actually
being with that person absolutely yeah
and honestly to me that's [__]
because if all she cares about is a
piece of paper in the ring and the party
and all that sort of stuff
because I mean there's people that get
married and don't even have kids right
like they just want to get or she wants
to get married
that's all that they care about is the
safety component of it right they just
care about the fact that now that she's
married the law has her ass protected
she can get half of your [__]
a woman is truly virtuous and in love
with you and thinks that you're the best
that she can get she'll look past the
whole I want to get married thing right
you know if she's good solid character
and you're not about it because you
don't want to complicate your life
unnecessarily she will stay I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out